cyber criminals are getting more and
more sophisticated and successful
they can harness the power of millions
of computers by remote control hooking
them up to a butt net to attack the
sites of companies or organizations
and cause them to crash
private individuals are persuaded to
transfer money by spam emails
anyone who downloads unfamiliar software
or opens dubious email attachment can
become part of an illegal botnet without
realizing it
scientists at the fraunhofer institute
for computer graphics research in
darmstadt have developed visualization
programs that can reveal the complex
relationships within such botnets
quickly and simply
and help pinpoint the perpetrators
the software enables the complex links
to be recognized as visual patterns
the kind of information that experts can
glean from this data are things like
telephone numbers the email addresses
that are used in these emails or the
account details when people are asked to
transfer money and specialist firms or
law enforcement agencies can make use of
that
james twellmeyer is a trained
mathematician
every day he handles huge amounts of
internet data some of it contains highly
interesting information
yet that is not apparent at first glance
he and a colleague have developed a
software program that brings this
information to light
all of a sudden it's possible to trace
links in a spam campaign and phone
numbers or email addresses are revealed
we can use the information that we
gain from the spam campaigns
to
improve our understanding of the
strategies which spammers use so that we
can better protect the citizens
and also use that give that information
to law enforcement agencies to try and
catch the criminals behind the spam
frequently internet users become
unwittingly caught up in a criminal bach
net after downloading bogus antivirus
software from untrustworthy internet
sites
the fraunhofer researchers analyze and
create visualizations of such scams
their work has revealed that criminals
test out their methods a few days before
rolling them out
such tests involve just a few dozen
internet sites
subsequently several thousand sites are
registered so that the illegal malware
is spread as widely as possible
if we could learn to
see
these kinds of campaigns the preparation
for this campaign
long before the main campaign took place
then we could perhaps prevent
this from happening in the future
of course individual internet users also
have to protect themselves by running
up-to-date anti-virus software and by
updating their operating systems
regularly
beware too of opening attachments from
unknown sources and visiting
untrustworthy sites
and the visualization software from
darmstadt should also make surfing safer
by helping security specialists and the
police to nail cyber criminals